[Music]
in this lecture we will move to the
opposite side of the world from the
mediterranean
while in the west the new roman empire
was expanding
in the east another great empire the
chinese han was also spreading
just like in the west the han empire
came into conflict with tribal people as
it expanded imposed new rules about
family life and stimulated rebellions
here in the east we will follow the
fortunes of two sisters in vietnam who
rebelled against the powerful han empire
it's difficult to write about trung
truck and her sister trung yi
because the sources of information are
few
and the contemporary texts were written
by the chinese
but i think the effort is worth it
because even today the trung sisters
have become symbols of vietnamese
identity and their struggle for freedom
when i traveled in vietnam and saw their
statues and festivals i wondered who
they were and what they did
here i can tell you what they did
who they were as women remains elusive
but what matters most is how they became
symbols of freedom for the people of
vietnam
i'll begin their story in the year 25 in
the red river delta in vietnam
where troch and yi grew up
this region had been conquered by the
han dynasty of china more than a hundred
years earlier but life in the delta was
about to change
pulling the region into rebellion
first let's look at life in the delta to
get an idea of traditional vietnam
culture that was about to change
the tribes of this delta had lived here
for centuries and they prospered because
of the richness of the river
the red river rises in china and rushes
along for some 750 miles down through
mountain gorges before it spreads into
the delta
this triangular region of some 5 000
square miles contains rich lowlands as
the river system empties into the gulf
of tonkin near hanoi
the region is full of mangrove swamps
many species of water birds and vicious
saltwater crocodiles
villagers built houses on stilts to keep
out the water
and the animals this region had been
ruled by legendary kings in the hung
dynasty who had ruled from about 2800
bce
these rulers tattooed crocodiles on
their thighs to capture the courage of
the fierce beasts and to serve as tokens
to keep the animals away
recognizing these tattoos the chinese
for centuries referred to vietnam as the
land of the crocodile men
the kings lived at the borders of the
lowland delta and the neighboring hills
so they could control both regions
trung truck and trung yi were related to
the legendary hung kings on their
maternal side
this noble relationship gave them some
license to rule
and as we will see they would take
advantage of it
the villagers in the delta prospered
because of the rich rice fields that
they irrigated from the rising waters of
the red river the chinese had perfected
the domestication and cultivation of
rice in wet patties some 10 000 years
earlier
and the spread of rice down to the red
river delta had been lost in the mists
of time
here in vietnam the cultivation had been
firmly established and the delta
produced two abundant crops a year
people cultivated the rice helped by
their water buffalos
the people were called the loch by the
chinese and the name refers to the
vietnamese way of irrigating their rice
fields
the villages also grew rich on trade
that extended north to china and south
to the mekong delta and beyond
besides their abundant rice the
vietnamese traded their natural
resources like copper iron gold silver
and jade
they even grew rich exporting cowrie
shells much prized by the chinese as
symbols of fertility and luck
the loch tribes had learned to cast
bronze in about a thousand bce and still
used bronze tools and weapons in the
year 25.
today archaeologists
call this bronze age in vietnam the
dongasan culture
their most striking artifact was a
bronze drum that they cast and decorated
beautifully
some of the drums were of an
extraordinary size they could weigh up
to 159 pounds and required huge amounts
of smelted copper
but the drums sounded the heartbeat of
the villages and clans that spread
throughout the delta and the neighboring
highlands
they were played for feasts and funerals
and they called the clan's warriors
together for war
as we will see
soon the two noble trung sisters would
sound the drums for war
to begin to understand the origins of
the war we first must understand
something about the social life of the
vietnamese and the status of their women
traditional viet society was based on
clans not on nuclear families and within
these clans women carried a great deal
of sovereignty
in fact some anthropologists consider
the dongsan culture to be matriarchal
with a child's mother being much more
important than ties of paternity
young women were free to choose lovers
at spring festivals and if a girl became
pregnant during these events the young
man was to go to her clan marry her and
be accepted as a son-in-law
if she did not get pregnant she was free
to choose another young man
mothers were responsible for raising the
children and proverbs echo this ancient
time as they say a spoiled child is
attributable to the mother or
grandmother
or if a child does wrong it's the mother
who bears responsibility
this responsibility extended into
adulthood
and women and grandmothers were
regularly consulted about the plans and
fortunes of their clan
choc ani's mother was a widow who raised
her two daughters on her own
and this was solidly within the
matriarchal tradition
she taught the girls skills usual for
both women and men
the girls learned to raise silkworms and
they also learned to make roasted
silkworm poopie which is a popular dish
in north vietnam today
but the girls were also brought up to
lead outside the home
their mother also had her daughters
trained in the martial arts sword
fighting and archery and they learned to
ride the war elephants that accompanied
the armies through the jungles
according to legend trung trock the
elder daughter was very heroic
courageous and good at bold stratagem
in 111 bc
expanding han dynasty of the chinese
extended southward and conquered most of
north vietnam
the chinese ruled the rich red river
delta province as well as the two
regions north and south of the delta so
they controlled the whole gulf of tonkin
for over a century the chinese rule
rested lightly on the land of the lock
the clan system remained in place and
women continued to wield a good deal of
authority
the drums still sounded through the
hills and clans gathered together to
celebrate and sometimes fight among each
other
the chinese influence was felt most
strongly in the prosperity that grew as
trade from the han empire extended all
the way to the west connecting to the
roman empire across the famous silk road
the chinese presence showed in garrisons
placed in the provinces but they were
only a token force
however
in 25 ce
events far to the north in the han
empire created changes that would affect
the provinces far to the south in
vietnam
what was going on in the north
a brief revolution that overthrew the
han emperor for about 16 years caused a
backlash that rippled down into the
delta changing the status quo
the han empire that had been established
in 206 bce
experienced a brief lapse in rule when a
rebellion introduced a new dynasty the
jinn
this dynasty lasted only from 9 ce to 23
ce and was ruled only by one emperor
the newly restored han dynasty is called
the eastern han because its emperors
moved the capital from shang east
to luoyang the eastern han empire
continued for another 200 years
until 220c
you